[Music]
well fiftieth anniversary they gave it
their all sounds like a very backhanded
compliment didn't it
am i foreshadowing who knows what the
heck am i wearing
Osgood that's what I'm wearing hey hey
hey I got the glasses that match I don't
have the inhaler though oh well we roll
with it
so the day of the doctor the 50th
anniversary special three doctors
including one who it's effectively his
only outing in the show proper with John
Hurt as the war doctor the return of the
Zygons a resolution ish for the fate of
Gallifrey from the end of the time war
this is juggling a lot and it's an odd
experience to watch it I haven't
rewatched this one in a while but I have
rewatched it since it aired because I do
enjoy it I think I'm a little bit more
critical of it now than I was when I
first reviewed it in what might have
been the first Doctor Who review on this
channel actually I think so and I say
that because I look at it now and I know
how some of the things that I thought it
was doing or would have a more lasting
impact over the course of the show
didn't pan out and I'll try not to dwell
on those things cuz that's not
necessarily the fault of this episode
though it is the fault of the writer of
this episode cos he was also the one who
failed to pick up on this stuff later so
I I feel just by being annoyed at Moffat
cuz like you planted stuff here that you
then did not do anything with ah
whatever you think about Davies he did I
come pretty complete loop
with everything he was working on during
his time he didn't leave a lot of stones
unturned for what he could have worked
with anyways oh boy this this is
starting negative which is annoying
because I do enjoyed this episode it is
a fun watch it has really enjoyable
chemistry between pretty much everybody
who's in it so let's talk about the
doctors in this with this is still
during Mass Smith's era so he gets to be
basically front and center which I think
if I were to nail down the one thing
that I do feel is like a tangible Fault
within this fiction I really do think
this should have been much more solidly
from the war doctors perspective through
most of it I think because it's taking
place during Matt Smith's era they felt
the need to you know you know have him
lead us into a lot of this she gets the
coda at the end and I mean I get it it's
his time as the doctor but especially
now knowing that we were not gonna get
John Hurt on-screen again playing this
part I wish this had more fully been his
story than it is and I wish that for you
know beyond the fact that I think it
would have been better use of the talent
it's also because I don't rank the war
doctor very highly when I when I look at
all the doctors not because he's bad but
just because I don't connect with him
but I feel like I should have and I
could have if he was if he was granted
more screen time and honestly Matt Smith
didn't need more then that's not to say
that he didn't use the time he had well
or that he didn't deserve it or whatever
but this was a once in a lifetime event
we did not need to be so heavily focused
on the current doctor especially because
he's gonna get his proper sign-off in
the next episode or special so that's an
annoyance for me John Hurt I have more
appreciation of what he's doing this
time watching it that I think I have
previously I don't know if that's
because I
listen to the first series of the war
doctor I'm inclined to think not because
I didn't actually like the first series
of the of the audio drama of the war
doctor that he was in particularly much
but I think I was I was really looking
for what he was doing more this time
because I I love John Hurt so I want to
like the war doctor more than I do so I
think I was really kind of zooming in on
on what he did a bit more this time and
he does bring a lot of good things to it
where he really finally starts to click
from he's actually towards the end when
the burdens been lifted while John Hurt
is very good at performing a doctor who
is worn down by war and just time the
sheer volume of time and what he's been
doing with his time just weighing down
on him and make him feel so done John
Hurt's incredibly good at that but
that's also not what I want
from the doctor but towards the end
where he you know who where he's saying
goodbye to everybody or when he he when
the three of them you know realized what
they can do and he has he gets that
twinkle in his eye
that's what my oh oh there it is and I'm
not gonna say I wish that had been in
the episode more because given the place
where he is as a character I'm not sure
you could justify him having a bit more
of that twinkle but like that's that was
something that I really did kind of take
to heart a bit more but it is by far the
minority of what he does Tennant I mean
Tennant slips back into this role very
easily I will say though a lot of
Tennant segments particularly the humor
and the jokes the kind of lazy and
they're very formulaic by the time the
things done I mean how many times is it
gonna do the he mistake he thinks
something is as I gone but it's not as I
gone thing I mean they do it three times
rule of threes I guess automatically
makes it justified except no it doesn't
you
each time you see the punchline coming
even outside the rule of threes you see
the punchline coming within the scene
itself in isolation you can figure out
where this is going every dang time and
they draw it out I think it's just it
just makes me like ah its embarrassment
humor which I don't enjoy and never will
so and like Moffat knows how to write
Tennant I feel like he didn't you know
what I think the thing is if I were to
actually break down the writing of the
three doctors of 1110 and the war doctor
I actually think tends got the weakest
portion of the script to work with and
his presence feels the most obligatory I
mean 11 like I said this was his era and
he does feel like he has a place in a
presence in the story the war doctor
absolutely Tennant feels much more along
for the ride and as a result he is he's
not bad because he's David Tennant as
the doctor so he's good and fun and his
energy keeps you glad that he's there
but he has the least function out of the
three of them and I think his parts as
scripted not him as a performer but as
scripted bring beliefs to the table I do
like that for the most part he gets
along with Matt Smith I mean they clash
a little bit but knowing that it's sort
of a traditional thing that the doctor
doesn't get along with themselves and
all but also knowing that those two are
kind of a cut from a similar cloth it
makes sense to me that they would get
along pretty well so I'm good with that
Matt Smith does actually very well in
this he has a lot to play with there's a
lot of fun moments there's a lot of very
heavy emotional moments and he gets to
deliver a lot with just a look which I
anytime an actor is given the
opportunity to do that I will always
treasure it because you give an actor
who can nail it the opportunity to say
everything with just an expression and
they managed to pull it off mmm-mwah
loved it Claire was fine
I mean she's she's very much back
rounded in this because it's not about
her and it's not about the impossible
girl so she's just serving the standard
companion role which is fine
that's good I like her there keep her
there stop building series plots around
it ah later problems get off it
so uh then we've got Kate Stewart is
back she's really good in this I I'm I'm
gonna dread each subsequent apparent she
has cuz my memory is that she the
writing on her gets worse and worse and
worse every time she shows up but she's
still good here she was good and power
of three and she's good here she has
that gumption and that strength and that
integrity that you want from somebody in
the kind of position of power that she
has and that you would also want from
someone who's effectively a legacy
character being the daughter of the
Brigadier so she needs to bring that
gravitas in that sense of yet she's not
messing around and she does she brings
exactly that so I thought she did a very
good job Queen Elizabeth was fine um
I don't love that their answer to why
the Queen wanted the doctor dead when
she saw him in the Shakespeare Code was
woman scorned that's that's a cheap
explanation for that I don't love that
it's one of those things that I wish
they'd left up in the air and like had
never addressed what what he did to take
off Queen Elizabeth and that could just
be left hanging there was like one of
those adventures we never saw instead we
see it as like oh she's just mad cuz he
married her and ran off
that's stupid so I don't love that but
she performs it pretty well she has she
has a couple of really good moments her
gushing over Tennant I could I could
take it or leave it but like when she's
when she reveals herself of having faked
her way as being the Zygon versions and
it never even occurred to these people
that I wasn't the Zygon I and I am more
than capable taken cameras of them like
cool I there we go
dig it like she Queen Elizabeth wasn't
effective diplomat and leader so this
that kind of deception yeah at least
your strengths that's in her wheelhouse
I like it Billie Piper as the moment
sort of channeling bad wolf I really
like a lot first of all I love visually
I love this look and I love the vibe
that Billie Piper brings to this part
because it's not Rose Tyler and does it
feel like Rose Tyler and it it has this
more slightly off-putting almost
ethereal sort of presence that she
brings to it
and I love what it brings out of John
Hurt so I love those interactions I
really dug that I like the moment a lot
a lot a lot
I again one of those things that I kinda
wish we could have had more of I'm not
sure how you could do it but I dig that
I like that quite a bit talking about
the plot so here's what sort of odd
about this thing it's a bit weird in a
way that in something following on from
the name of the doctor which is going to
tackle this surprise doctor we never
knew about before is John Hurt and it's
got a sink so much time into a Zygon
plot that does not in any way tie
directly into the war doctor or the
Daleks or the time well minorly the time
war because they lost their home planet
and that that's why they want to take
over Earth but that that seems to have
had them like with every single
villainous race crying out loud but at
first glance there isn't really a reason
to match these stories together the
Saigon invasion plot and the war doctor
and the Daleks and Gallifrey
but what it where it all comes together
is in the resolution in the tail-end
with the doctor and well tenant and
Smith's doctors and all that war doctors
there too but those two are front and
center setting this thing off where you
have these two versions of Kate Stewart
that needs to negotiate a truce between
Zygons and humans and they temporarily
wiped their memory so they don't know
which ones is I on which ones a human
meaning they're going to come up with a
perfect compromise for both sides
because they don't know what side
they're actually on I mean that's really
cool but what's great about that is
you're there in a situation where case
two have really very firmly she has no
choice but to let this let this black
archive that the Zygons have gotten in
to blow up and it's gonna blow up most
of London she is prepared to make that
sacrifice to keep them from taking over
the world and that's a calculation that
makes sense to her and it's an
equivalent calculation to the doctors
decision to use the moment to wipe out
Daleks and the Time Lords for the sake
of the rest of the universe and it's
only when the story gets to the gets to
it's the Zygons story gets to its climax
so you see that the doctor has to stop
someone from making that decision that
the connections actually get made
because up to that point like I said
there's a lot of reason but you bring it
to that and you get to have John Hurt's
doctor see that happen and realize like
you know this is what I should be doing
I can't be the one making this horrible
choice I need to be the one finding
something anything other than that so it
becomes important and they fit together
in that way now given that the way in
which they fit together
thumb attica Lee doesn't really come
together until the very end you'd be
forgiven for spending a good chunk of
the episode going oh this is fun but
what
and so the whole thing with saving
Gallifrey I've got a lot of mixed
feelings about this and there's there's
a number of things about it in general
so the thing one broadly speaking I
don't have a problem with Gallifrey
being saved what I had hoped at the time
this did not pan out but what I had
hoped because it ends with this note of
the doctor was going to hopefully one
day find Gallifrey again it was my hope
that nobody was going to do that at the
very least Moffat wasn't gonna do it and
nobody would do it for a very long time
that that would be basically sort of at
some point goal something for the doctor
to work towards but not actually get to
anytime soon well that didn't happen
ends up hey ends up coming up again a
lot sooner
like soon enough that it's like what
what was the point but the other thing
that I thought I kind of have mixed
feelings about and I say mixed feelings
because it I could I can make either
side of this argument because there is
an interesting emphasis put on this idea
of all the children of Gallifrey that
are that died that burn or would have
burned have the doctor actually done
this and he thought he did but it turns
out he didn't yeah and that's actually
an interesting acknowledgement because
all we've seen in new who of Gallifrey
was basically the High Council the
people who were gonna try and bring an
end to time and it's like book screw
those guys
but then you have the reminder like no
they're not the only ones on this planet
part of me wants to say that his rescue
effort shouldn't have involved the
military council or the High Council of
Gallifrey and really should have just
been the civilians because knowing what
we do about those villains and the fact
that Rassilon is going to come back
sort of with a different actor and be
freaking pointless Oh God
anyways um knowing all that it seems it
kind of annoys me that the ruling
authority of Gallifrey was brought back
but then again again having the doctor
decide to only save the civilians puts
him right back to making a decision that
he should not be making which is
deciding you I'm gonna let you die I
could save you but I'm gonna let you die
and this story is basically about
refusing to do that so that wouldn't
work
the matically either so I get why it's
just for some reasons it kind of bugs me
but let's talk about the best thing in
the episode Tom Baker the great curator
I love this scene so much I love his
delivery of these lines I love this
giddiness that you're getting on of Matt
Smith being in the scene with him
I love the hopefulness of it I love the
implication that this is the doctor much
later because this I'm not gonna say
they can't roll back from this it's
Doctor Who they can rewrite continuity
however they freaking want they can they
have they will but what this does is
this creates a perfect eternal non
ending for dr. ooh what I mean by that
is if we take it as a given that the
great curator is the doctor at a much
later point in his life at some much
later regeneration having aged who knows
how long and decided to basically retire
and be curator for a bit if we take that
as a given which pretty much everything
in the episode points to that being the
case like he himself is like oh maybe I
was you or maybe I wasn't but you know
who knows but let's be honest everything
points to that so if we take that as a
given what that means is
because they're never actually going to
do a series with Tom Baker adds the
great curator that that's not gonna be a
thing that means that the show can't
have a standard endpoint it can't decide
and then the doctor dies at best it has
to go and the doctor went off and had
more adventures and we know the doctor
had to go off and have more adventures
because we haven't seen the doctor come
back to be the great curator yet and we
never will which means the stories never
end I love that I love the scene in of
itself and I loved it for what it does
overall I do enjoy this I have my
nitpicks about it in my little like yeah
that could have been a little bit better
or some like I don't know how they could
be better but I feel like something good
work better sort of things about it but
at the end of the day for as much as
this thing's trying to carry the weight
of a 50th anniversary three doctors one
of which we've never seen before the
return of Zygons for the first time
since 70s this does a pretty admirable
dang job of balancing all that that's
solid it's a good piece of work day in
the doctor what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down the comments let's
talk about it you know the things
they're the things that appease the
algorithm the likes the shares the
subscribes the comments which I already
mentioned I've also got a patreon link
in the description that's greatly
appreciated too but I also don't have to
do any of it end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]